hello everyone and welcome to the
Nations Cup Super Final in a game
between you young versus Wesley soul so
it's China versus United States and it's
probably the best game of the Super
Final and of course a very important one
as ye lost this game to Fabiana core one
away you've went for a Scandinavian the
Queen to d8 Scandinavian at that and
Fabi didn't really seem like he had
problems winning that game so it's very
important for now for Wesley to do well
so he also scores score some points for
Team USA but also I have no idea why
it's called the super final like if
there was no final way why call it the
super final I don't know if it's just to
make it appear more important or is
there actually a difference between a
final or a super final but I just
thought of that that it was very
interesting but yeah getting back to the
game yongi with the white pieces opens
with d4 we have Knight to f6 c4
we have east six by Wesley Knight to c3
and Bishop to b4 we go into the
nimzo-indian defense and knight of three
d5 are we transpose into the ragas in
defense of the Queens gambit declined we
have Queen to b3 attacking the bishop
and now c5 defending the bishop we have
D captures and c5 now again there's the
threat of just Queen captures on b4 and
knights to a6 now defending and also
attacking you will be able to capture it
with with the bishop so here C captures
on d5 and now that there are no no no
names the word Quinta if I was played
and also Queen captures and d5 is a non
move since the knight cannot capture as
the the pin exists here and you and you
already had this game against Hari
Krishna we're hardcore Krishna went for
Queen to a5 but here we have a knight
characters on d5 and it is already a new
move so already as a move seven we have
a completely new game and now here of
course you cannot keep defending the
pawn so here youngji goes for c6 he
gives up the point a mess of Wesley's
pawn structure here but Wesley first
goes for Queen to a5 and now you don't
have time for this
if you capture capture then you just
give black too much development and your
King is still stuck on e1 so it would be
it would be very dangerous to play this
so instead Bishop to d2 just adding
another defender to the c3 Knight and
only now
Wesley captures in c6 we have g3
preparing to fianchetto the lights for a
bishop and now Knight captures on c3 we
have B captures forcing the bishop to
move with Bishop to e7 and now Bishop to
G 2 preparing castles we have castles by
both sides and now II five just grabbing
more more space in the center and the
Queen from a5 nicely defends the pawn
and now Queen back to C - probably with
with ideas of just the c5 so maybe if
the knight moves the Queen also guards
the bishop and also just clearing the B
file for the rook so black doesn't like
his queen on the same diagonal as the
bishop so Queen back to c7 also keeping
around the e5 pawn and now Queen to b4
going after the e5 pawn so f6 now
defending it but on the other hand
you've played f6 and it's well it's too
early to tell if this is one of those
positions where it's actually okay to
play of six so here Queen to c4 with
check this now opens up this diagonal
from the bishop to the rook or also
there might be some pressure on the c6
pawn and it's just just useful move so
King to h8 and now first Bishop to e3
controlling the knight on e6 the knight
now has no squares yes you can go to be
eight and this is exactly what Wesley
does so he has to bring the knight into
the game somehow he wants to play a
brush up to a sixth put pressure on the
Queen and on the e2 pawn so rook F to D
1 and now bush of the a6 attacking the
Queen and the pond and there's no way to
defend the pawn but you never intended
to defend the pawn so Queen east six
again he keeps playing against the
knight on b8 if the knight can develop
the rook also is stuck on a a so here
you're guarding the d7 square so the
knight cannot be developed but you give
up the e2 pawn which is okay so Bishop
captures any to rook D - you know the
development before material and the
bishop back to a6 and now Knight to the
h4 so already White has a very nice
position with control of the d7 square
so bright black will
troubles developing night can come to f5
night can maybe come to g6 in the future
as you've weakened the g6 score by
playing f6 maybe some sacrifices will be
possible we'll see
so now Wesley goes back Russia back to
c8 he forces the Queen to a less active
square Queen back to c4 and now f5 and
okay you grab more space you are
preparing Bishop characters on h4 but
you still have problems all of your
pieces on the Queen side are undeveloped
so tonight's to f3 and now h6 taking
away the g5 square from the knight and
the bishop and now we have rook a to d1
nicely doubling up on the D file and the
King to h7 just improving the safety of
the King not allowing any ideas 990
jumps in the future maybe so the knife
cannot come to g6 and now h4 so just
grabbing more space starting in the
attack on the Kings side we worked the
f6 adding another that a defender to the
6th rank also the c6 point is now
defendants who you might be able to
start developing your your knight and so
on
but here comes Knight to g5 with Czech
and we enter the position from the
thumbnail where black has to decide
whether to capture the knight or not and
the capturing the knight is in fact the
best move there's a it's not at all
clear how the attack should happen so
here H captures on g5 we have H captors
and g5 and now you have to move the rook
your rook is under attack and here if
rook the e6 then the attack continues
and the game continues rook to e6 is a
fine move for black however rook to g6
is not and by playing rook to g6 would
Wesley did I'm not gonna tell you what
he did I mean I'm instead gonna ask you
to pause the video and try to win this
game for white well I give you a couple
of seconds and then we're gonna discuss
what's the difference between rook g6
and rookie 6 so well I give you a couple
of seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on
figuring out that the rook on g6
prevents the King from reaching the g6
square so that's a problem
and also that well Quinta h4 would be
deadly if the king could not go back to
g8
so how do you
you solve this puzzle you simply
prevented the king from going back to g8
and this is exactly what young he does
he plays better up to d5 and takes away
the g8 Square from the black King now
Queen to h4 is the deadly threat of
course the bishop cannot be captured as
the Queen on c7 hangs and also if you
try something like a bunch of characters
and g5 to take away the h4 square from
the Queen then you get Bishop g8 check
King to h8 and Bishop characters and g5
and after the Rookery characters now
just Rock the 8th and it's a game over
there are nasty discoveries incoming
Queen to h4 is still a threat and if we
try rogue g4 to prevent again Queen to
h4 it's in then comes Queen f1 and
there's no defense against Queen to h3
really really a wonderful stuff so after
this Bishop to d5 Wesley of course has
to prevent Queen to h4 somehow he plays
f4 now again puts pressure on the bishop
here but now comes the bishop to e4 and
you don't just get to trade something
because Wes because Young is not in the
business of trading because after F
captures an e3 you have Queen to f7 and
now it's just the game over and there's
nothing you can do here regardless of
what black plays you still cannot move
the bishop as the Queen hangs on c7 and
after you capture something doesn't
really matter what then you get Bishop
captures King goes back and just a nice
checkmate
so after Bishop to e4 we have Bishop
captures on g5 now hoping for Bishop
captures on g6 but like we said you is
not in the business of training he goes
rook the d6 introduces another rook into
the attack and of course this rook
cannot move is pinned so Bishop back to
f6 now and not allowing the rook
captures rook and now again not rush of
characters in g6 in chess the threat is
very often stronger than the execution
so King to g2 again introducing another
look into the attack via rook to h1 and
here Wesley finds a way to deal with
this he plays f3 with check now if the
bishop moves the rope is no longer
pinned so here we have King captures on
f3 and now Bishop to g4 check winning
the exchange but it doesn't matter King
to g2 we have Bishop characters on d1
and now we have rook characters on d1
now it's the same as it was so the King
still has no access to the g8 square the
rook cannot move and so the king cannot
go to h6 black has nothing look to h1
will win the game on the next move
regardless of what what black plays
there's there's no playing this so yeah
really really wild game and with this
victory China scores a victory over the
United States and it is China who wins
the Nations Cup the online nations
covered by a feeding and chess calm even
though the match was a tie Fabiana
Khurana defeated Wei Yi Nakamura drew
against Dingley rain and eating a crush
drew against - so it's 2-2 but because
China won't won the previous part of the
competition then they have more points
and they win they win the first place in
the online Nations Cup so really really
wild stuff in wild games and do we or do
we not award you an e with a morphe head
it's a good question I'm saying we do
there we go
there's a nice morphe head for yongi i
was actually thinking about giving it to
him or not I just I was just trying to
make the moment more intense so I hope
you enjoyed that as well and yeah that's
it for the game I do hope you enjoyed it
and that you've enjoyed this short
coverage of the online Nations Cup I
would like to thank David Kaiser Robert
su coach of Mario raccoon Robert did
Mark and the Pierre Revis Brutus for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon
continuing the morphe saga we're gonna
check up on Leo just zero since we we
kind of stopped doing that after the
beginning of the Magnus Invitational
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and of course whatever else
happens in the chess world so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your Sunday